I'll keep talking about the enormous
scope of cyber security and all the
lucrative job offers inside that but
I'll keep getting this one question and
it's quite obvious why will you do a job
apart from all the other reasons there
is one reason that stands first and that
is money and there is a lot of money in
cyber security honestly I'm not
exaggerating but many people won't
believe me because they will expect
blacks of packages as a fresher
everything takes time and if you are
consistent if you have the right skill
set no one is stopping you from earning
millions or even lacks per month so gear
up for this video as I will be sharing
the top 5 most popular job profiles in
cyber security and what are their
packages and salaries in India as well
as abroad for freshers as well as
experienced so let's get started first
of all this list is not in any order
these are the top five profiles that are
trending right now and will only boom in
the future and also the figures I will
tell you will be your fixed base pay the
concept of CTC involves a lot of
stockholdings other benefits in the
number so I I'll be telling you just
what you will get in your monthly
paycheck excluding taxes number one
penetration testers these people are
also called by the name of security
analyst security Engineers based on the
job profile and Company but to give you
a clear idea these people proactively
identify threats and issues in an
organization's critical infrastructure
both in their software and Hardware
products to let the owner know and fix
the issues appropriately and they are
immensely important to any ID dependent
business and companies are slowly
realizing their worth and increasing
their pay but getting hard as a fresher
here it's a bit tricky because this is a
skill heavy job to talk about salaries
in India as a fresher you can get six to
seven LPA in the starting this will also
include your training budget and other
benefits you can do any certification
from a popular vendor such as offensive
security EC Council or Sans and also you
get chance to visit and attend offline
conferences namely nelcon besides orasp
even Defcon and black hat if you get
some experience of two three years your
salary can jump to 12 to 15 LPA but if
you keep working for five or more years
your salary may even go up to 25 to 30
LPA if I talk about foreign countries
when you get paid in dollars your salary
can be 100K dollars per year when you
start and if you keep working for five
plus years of experience your salary can
go to 160 to 180k per year these people
are also called red teamers by the way
speaking of red teaming these jobs are
really very difficult because the people
here are really not competent and red
teaming requires immense creativity and
deep conceptual knowledge of the whole
network stack so learning pen testing is
not very easy but I can make you
skillful enough with a guided course
that can even give you a professional
certificate from IIT kanpur I'm talking
about simply learns professional
certificate program in cyber security
red teaming in which you will be taught
by expert faculties from IIT kanpur this
program is an online boot camp which
runs for six months in which you will be
taught by industry experts how to
identify and analyze threats at scale
and how to create strategies to secure
systems through Hands-On training in
real world cases you will also get a
chance to attend live sessions in latest
AI Trends and also generative Ai and
llms this will teach you the most
popular red teaming tools used and also
help you to develop a hacker's mindset
and also you can manage threats and
overall security posture of an
organization at the end you will be
getting three Indus SV projects where
you will do real world vulnerability
assessments on real world targets and
which will help you to Showcase your
skill set to your future employers and
also not to forget you will get a
professional certificate from IIT kanpur
as well simply learn also provides you
job assistant so that you can land your
dream job the hiring network is right in
front of you some big names you already
thought of so to be eligible for this
program you should have at least one
bachelor's degree in a tech field you
should have basics of programming and
cyber security skills and not required
but if you have one or two years of
professional work experience that will
be better application is really very
simple just go to the description click
on the link review all the program
details click on apply now and then it
will ask you some details fill all the
details required and just submit and
wait for the reward back and believe me
there are not many good programs that
will teach you so much in so less so
don't think wise just get started number
two security analyst these are the blue
teamers they are also called by the name
sock analyst cyber security analyst
forensic analyst and these people are
constantly watching out for real-time
threats so that they can alert and
prevent them from causing any harm and
they are the first line of defense of
any infosec department and this is the
reason why they are required in any info
Department even when they don't have
proactive pen testers they will
definitely have blue teamers because
they are the first one to be hired they
are defensive in nature if I talk about
salaries in India as a fresher you can
get 5 to 7 LPA for two to three hours of
experience you can get 10 to 15 LPA and
for five plus years of experience you
can go up to 20 to 25 LPA in U.S these
people are paid slightly less than the
pen testers they can start from 100K per
year and they can go up to 150 to 170k
in five plus years of experience number
three cyber security manager they are in
very high demand right now because
organizations are investing huge money
in security infrastructure because
everyone knows how important is data
today just like software development
teams have project managers we have
security managers so they decide the
plan of action for IT issues and data
breaches and they create policies for
secure functioning of I.T assets and
they also onboard and manage security
projects and delegate them to the team
members rightfully and help maintain the
overall security posture and of course
you cannot be hired as a manager right
away you need to have at least five
years of experience in a security domain
and then you can be starting as a
manager for starting of course the
salaries are very high in India these
people start from 15 to 20 LPA and they
can even go to 30 to 40 LP if they keep
working for four to five years and some
people will even touch 50 LPA in us they
start from 110 to 120k per year for more
experience of about 5 years they can go
to 200k as well number four security
auditor it often gets overlooked by
beginners because it doesn't appeal to
them and doesn't Fascinate them but it
is a very responsible job and
importantly undoubtedly it's very
important in infosec Department we often
need to comply to certain government
regulatory policies when we deal with
customer data or public data such as
Bank information and financial
information pii or health information so
we need to comply and follow certain
standards so all the infrastructure is
regularly audited by these teams for
compliance and they are also responsible
for identification of risk and issues
they are also called Risk Managers IIT
Auditors or GRC so they ultimately are
responsible for managing risk and
compliance and of course here as well
you cannot join as a fresher you need a
responsible experience but in India when
you start you can get 10 to 15 LPA and
then the growth is even better so after
three to four years even you can go up
to 25 to 30 LBA in us the median is 120
to 130k and if you work for three to
four years you can even go up to 180k
number five CSO Chief Information
Security Officer he is the backbone of
the whole infosec department you are in
charge of the infosec you are
responsible for managing everything and
governing everything to protect the IIT
infrastructure keeping it in compliance
and you manage all the security teams
under you so from auditing to budgeting
to developing infosec policies to
procurement everything it's a complete
leadership role it's an ultimate job
where you will need to have at least 10
to 15 years of experience in security
and also need to work as a manager for
five plus years in managing a security
team the salaries are immense of course
if you land it in India when they start
they can easily get up to 30 to 40 LPA
and they can even go to uh 70 to 80 LPA
if in some good companies and also five
plus years and it's a top product based
companies in India they can even touch
100 LPA that is one crore and in U.S
it's even higher it starts from 300 to
350k and I'm not kidding but some offers
may even go up to 1 million USD per year
when you get experience for up to five
years so these are the top five cyber
security profiles you can apply now and
enjoy great packages and benefits but
again I'm not raising you to Cloud Nine
these packages are really very
subjective they will depend on a lot of
factors including company its size and
location I'm taking top mncs at the
reference number two your education
level number three job roles and
objectives number four Market Condition
it's not good right now of course
inflation and all number five your
performance so make sure you do your
research before applying and then you're
good to go in your career so I hope this
video gave you a right idea about the
benefits of a cyber security career and
what domains to choose and how to
proceed so all the best for your career
if you're planning for it and I'll see
you in the next video where I'll talk
about another cyber security landscape
so keep watching keep learning and
goodbye